dear colleagues please welcome to the
Joint meeting of Libra and farm
committees
which is held on the second anniversary
of
of a decision by the so-called
constitutional Court in Poland
on the de facto ban of abortion in
Poland
this hearing is organized jointly by two
joint committees farm and labor
committee therefore I would like to
welcome Vice chair Pietro Bartolo who
will Coach her this hearing with me I
would also like to welcome all the guest
speakers first of all a few words on my
part
as you know in Poland
and for two years now we have had the
law which in our evaluation and also to
the according to the evaluation of
parliament this law it is time to
amounts to the violation of Human Rights
this is what our two resolutions say
because we adopted to resolutions With a
View to a decision by the Polish
tribunal Court this legislative Nation
violates a fundamental human rights
treaties and
based on the recommendations in the
resolution the council should start a
procedure under article 7 of the EU
treaty
and this is also the position of our
committee but also European parliament's
position in the resolution we also call
upon the
a committee which I chair to organize a
fact-finding mission in Poland in order
to evaluate the situation of girls and
women with a view to analyze the
situation when it comes to access to
abortion services this Mission took
place about two weeks ago and today
during our meeting we will accept the
report from this Mission uh Fred matis
who is present today was head of the
mission dear colleagues we have to say
clearly and you will find the same thing
in the report from the mission that this
legislation barbaric legislation I am
not afraid to say this this barbaric law
has also caused victims we have at least
six documented cases of women
who
simply died because of this barbaric law
these six women are women whom we know
we know their names but a lot of girls a
lot of women
are unknown and our duty as the as both
committees is not only to talk about it
our duty is to fight for the rights
today I would like to show you something
this is something that best illustrates
this situation this hellish situation of
women in Poland this is the latest
report of the international
parental Hood Federation so this is the
most prestigious organization which
deals with sexual and Reproductive
Rights globally when this report was
presented
those who presented the report said that
on this map they ran out of colors they
ran out of this deep purple color
because Poland
because Poland is beyond any yardstick
so the situation in Poland is that bad
that so far so far
they're
there have never been a country
which would lower the standards when it
comes to reproductive Health rights that
much and this is our situation in Poland
and I would like to tell you and I am
also I base it also on the report from
the mission this report talks not only
about Polish women whose rights are
violated this report describes also the
situation of Ukrainian women and girls
who fleeing War they are also
escaping from Russian soldiers who rape
girls who rape women
and these women
if they want to use abortion they are
not able to do that in Poland so they
escape from one hell to find themselves
in another and we as Parliament as EU as
our farm committee we cannot turn our
Blind Eye to that therefore we organize
a long we are organized this hearing we
want to hear those who those women who
should be who should talk on this
subject and thank you for having
accepted the invitation today we are
also hosting a sister-in-law of Miss
Isabel of Miss Isabella from China who
was the first known victim of this
barbaric law so miss Isabella will give
her testimony this will be very
emotional and thank you very much for
your presence and now I would like to
give the floor to Mr Bartolo Vice
texture of the Libya committee Pietro
the floor is yours
thank you
thank you Robert piedron
for it thank you chair for these
introductory remarks
you have a very keen sensitivity to
these subjects and it is something that
is obvious
now the fam and liebe committees are
following very carefully what is
happening in terms of women's sexual and
reproductive health and rights in Poland
and with great concern
now since 2015 we've really seen a
backsliding of democracy rule of law and
fundamental rights in Poland and we've
been sounding the alarm on that on the
20th of December 2017 the commission
finally triggered article 7 that you
spoke of
Article 1 paragraph uh article 7
paragraph one teu in relation to the
Polish judicial reforms considering that
essential safeguards ensuring the
separation of powers between the
executive
and the Judiciary had effectively been
removed
the parliament expressed its
dissatisfaction about how slow the
procedure was going in the council and
immediately issued an interim report on
the 17th of September 2020 on this
matter
in its interim report the parliament
clearly stated that the main concerns in
poolum are Poland are as far follows the
functioning of the legislative and
electoral system the independence of the
Judiciary and the rights of judges and
the production of fundamental rights
unfortunately yet again we must
reiterate that removing Democratic
checks and balances and undermining
fundamental rights go hand in hand this
is not an abstract problem it has
serious consequences on human life
today's hearing will show that very well
on the 21st of October 2020 the ruling
party made a request and the Polish
constitutional tribunal thereby declared
one of the three exceptions allowing
legal abortion to be unconstitutional
this limited very severely the right to
abortion to the point of being almost
impossible to find that Health Care the
parliament's resolution of 26 November
2020 on the de facto ban on the right to
abortion in Poland highlighted the link
between the political capture of the
Polish constitutional tribunal and the
ruling of 21 October 2020 on
27 January 2021 the highly restrictive
abortion law
entered into force in Poland now this
entails a clear risk to women's lives a
risk with um potentially deadly
consequences as we've said and in some
cases we have actual
cases where this happened having said
all of that I should however like to
warmly welcome our speakers who are here
with us today to Bear witness to this
heartfelt drama allow me to pay tribute
to the family
who is bringing their story to us today
and to all of the families who lost
their relatives due to this de facto
abortion ban in Poland
I would like on this note to give the
floor back to Robert
so that he can present our speakers
thank you Pietro
and now we start
with the presentations and as a first I
will give the Florence for the sister in
love Isabella from strina Barbara
Scrabble who will present her testimony
from her sister-in-law I must tell you
that
Isabella was the first documented victim
of this barbaric legislation her face is
on the poster which we
prepared for the the hearing Isabella
was a young woman she was a dreamer she
was 30 years old as I remember when she
died and she's the first documented
victim of this barbaric legislation so
Barbara the floor is yours
foreign
good afternoon
my name is Barbara scrobel and I'm a
sister-in-law of the late Isabella from
China I'm speaking here today on behalf
of the family because those closest to
Isabella are still grieving are still in
pain and to this day they are not able
to speak in public about what has
happened Isabella was a 30 year old
woman a loving wife and mother for her
nine daughter
nine-year-old daughter Maya she was not
only a friend but also a guide Isabella
loved traveling wanted to show other
cultures to her child Isabella loved
life she enjoyed living
she liked accomplishing her objectives
as a businesswoman she had
a very well run hair salon
he had been trying to get pregnant again
for three years when she was 22 weeks
pregnant she got hospitalized and it
turned out there was no amniotic fluid
in the womb Edward's syndrome and the
high likelihood of fatal fetal
abnormalities have been diagnosed
however she was informed that because of
the restrictive
anti-abortion law the doctors were not
allowed to terminate pregnancy then and
then let me quote her text messages we
need to wait for the heartbeat to stop
this is because of the pis potentially
if my life is in danger perhaps they
will do something this is awful those
procedures
let me quote some other text messages
question are they going to induce labor
no they can't they need to wait for it
to start spontaneously or for the heart
to be to stop or for the waters to break
it needs to happen spontaneously those
procedures a tent amount to tormenting
mothers this is katinski's and dudas
doing they treat women as if they were
incubators
here I am reading out those messages
it's a testimony of a dying person I'm
saying it with a heavy heart is I knew
that she could die of sepsis she knew
she was being tortured forced to wait
for the fetus to die she also wrote in
her messages that the child was being
tormented as well the baby the fetus the
family wasn't allowed to visit Isabella
because of the covet restrictions either
stayed in touch with her family until 11
pm
shortly after midnight Iza died of a
septic shock
in this hospital she should have been
safe but help was refused she should
have been helped in accordance with the
current medical standards this has not
been done
when Isa was hospitalized she asked the
doctors the nurses for help
she was saying I want to live I want to
live for my family
she wanted to live for her husband and
her daughter Maya Maya her daughter will
never be able to hug her mom again Isa
was also worried about her mom and
brother for whom she was a great source
of support Maya the daughter wrote a
goodbye letter to her mom saying I love
you Mommy I can't believe you are dead I
will always remember you I will always
love you I will never forget you
Maya wanted her father to put this
letter as the last goodbye into the
coffin now Maya goes to the Grave comes
to the grave of her mom almost every day
brings teddy bears her schools artwork
she wants to be close medical errors
have been made no doubt about it but
here I am telling you
about a story which shows how law can
affect the life of one individual the
restrictive law has caused a chilling
effect
that's why Isabella died I was
personally told by a doctor that they
weren't able to do anything because of
the anti-abortion law Isabella died
people took to the streets in order to
express their solidarity in order to
protest against what had happened we
were touched but it also gave us
strength to fight for Isa and to fight
for other women who still had their
lives to live
I am here today because a state should
support women this new anti-abortion law
hurts women takes away their human
rights their freedom of choice their
freedom to decide about their bodies and
their lives Isa has paid a highest price
for this she paid with her life her life
was basically taken away from her I
would like to make a plea to call on to
you as decision makers let us make sure
that this never happens again that
nothing like this ever happens again to
any women let us not take away why it
was from their husbands and mothers from
their children not a single one more
thank you very much
thank you very much and now we will hear
the voice of Camila ference a lawyer
from the foundation for women and family
planning federa this is the foundation
that we met while in a Poland in our
community committee cooperates with this
foundation and this organization helps
women when it comes to access to sexual
and Reproductive Rights Madame ference
the floor is yours having me first of
all I want to thank you Barbara for this
amazing speech that
was the best way with those photos with
your memories to realize us to help us
realize that we actually lost one of us
our sister thank you a lot
[Applause]
dear all you've heard about Isabella's
case I want you to
um
see that we have more such similar cases
I want to show you some examples
next slide please
a few examples of women who lost their
lives in Poland only because they were
women at reproductive age and they got
pregnant in Poland
this is the case of eustina who was 34
years old when she died as a mother of
two boys in December 2020 in the
hospital in vodices in southern Poland
she gave birth to stillborn by cesarean
section she had sepsis infection because
of the medical negligence
criminal proceedings were discontinued
but pending still there is a pending
claim for compensation in her case
next slide please
we know the case of Anya from
schvidmitsa 32 years old who died in
June 2021 in schwietnitza hospital she
also gave birth to steelborn by
Caesarean section she always also had
sepsis infection and the criminal
proceedings in her case are staying
still being conducted
um by vrodsworth prosecution office
next slide please
and Marta who died in April 2022 in
katowice hospital she also also gave
birth to stillborn she also has
substance infection and criminal
proceedings in her case are still
pending also on both person for patients
rights is verifying the circumstances of
this case
and next slide please
and now is the time to pose a question
what do these cases have in common next
slide please
they are not only unfortunate cases and
exceptions in Poland no they are victims
of the restrictive anti-abortion law and
practice in Poland they are victims of
the pattern of treating a woman in
Poland as an object least important
that's
um
that has nothing to say and she's not
being asked what she wants and what she
needs
those women they are only exception
examples and we know more cases and
there are probably cases that we don't
know about they all are victims of
chilling effects on doctors who right
now in Poland are afraid of undertaking
activities that could be qualified of as
abortion those doctors wait too long to
induce birth of a stillborn they
procrastinate to remove dead fetus on
time they hesitate to remove ectopic or
other threatening pregnancy
and this way they threaten women's life
and health next slide please
this all leads to the reduction of the
standards of gynecological Healthcare in
Poland
and these negatively affect other
reproductive health services such as
access to perinatal standards prenatal
testing or contraceptives
as a result we know the statistics that
more and more women don't want to have
children don't want to get pregnant and
start families but more children are
born with severe and fatal defects and
that lead to their death shortly after
birth
and if those newborns survive the
families are barely provided with any
assistance in Poland next slide please
today in Poland contact with the public
health care system is just traumatizing
for all women
the trust between patients and Medicals
is lost as a consequence women's health
physical and mental as wealth women's
life and safety is at risk on a bigger
and bigger scale every day
which is not only horrifying in the
middle of Europe but it's also the
disaster of the modern Europe
the best illustration of the situation
is
um our work during two years the federa
my organization answers around 20 000
phone calls and 12 000 males we provided
122 to
1200 legal consultations concerning
access to abortion in Poland we
recognize the systemic violation of
women's rights on a massive scale so we
brought 30 cases to the European Court
of Human Rights
we also faced the problem of the
criminalization of abortion in Poland
for doctors and helpers
um
which ended up in the eustina's case
you stand as an activist who helped
domestic violence Survivor to have an
abortion because she wanted that those
one this woman wanted to have an
abortion and now yustina is being
prosecuted in Poland for just helping
and being
empathetic in the situation
but the most important question for
today is what do we need to be done
next slide please
and we need strong reaction and position
of the European Union
on abortion because abortion is not a
political or religious statement access
to abortion is actually the human right
and the universal experience of millions
of women all over the world
access to abortion allows to decide on
your future on the future of your family
on your body on your health
and this um
and this decision about abortion should
be in our hands in the hands of women
not in the hands of conservative
politicians doctors prosecutors or
judges
abortion is linked to the respect for
human dignity Freedom democracy equality
the rule of law and respectful for human
rights which are values of the European
Union and those values must be followed
by Poland
the EU competence in the field of Public
Health is shared with members States
especially in case of the threat to
Public Health
the EU should take action to make sure
that the standards of care is
uniformized on the level of European
union and access to Safe legal often
life-saving abortion should be
considered as a shared EU standard
abortion must be included in the
European Union's policies on health
safety and equality next slide please
Polish women should be treated the same
as other EU citizens in regards to
access to essential reproductive Health
Services
the EU needs to ensure that polish women
have access to Safe legal and free of
charge abortion on the territory of the
European Union
what is more organizations which
Advocate to access to abortion and
provide help to women need to be
financially supported
how to do it this is the question to you
honorable members of the parliament
but one thing should be clear
this is your duty not to leave Polish
women behind
because this is the reality and the
situation in Poland one day may be the
reality of your own country
thank you very much
I wanted to thank Barbara for this story
that she shared with us it was
incredibly moving
and extremely sad and of course I would
also like to thank you for these
comments as well
Camila they were extremely important I'd
like to give the floor now to Neil deta
Secretary of the European parliamentary
forum for sexual and Reproductive Rights
welcome back
to Parliament we are looking forward to
your presentation could you tell us also
about the
um case that has been brought against
you following that we had on the 24th of
February 2021 Alibi Femme meeting that
we discussed in which we discussed this
subject I'd like to give you the floor
now when you have seven minutes to for
your speech
um good afternoon everyone greetings
from uh from Thailand where I'm at the
international Family Planning conference
I'm sorry I could not be with you in
person but thank you nonetheless for
giving me the floor and also I'd like to
share my sympathies with the family of
Isabella for the trauma that has been
that has been fallen on on your family
and I'm very sorry to hear that
um just a few words to begin with about
EPF for those of you who don't know us
so we are a European parliamentary firm
for sexual and reproductive health and
rights we are a parliamentary Network
and we work with parliamentarians MPS
and neps from all Democratic parties
um and we we prioritize sexual and
reproductive health and drives so I
think this is why we're here today and
and as the as the moderator said as the
chair said we testified that at the
previous Hearing in February of last
year next slide please
uh next okay thank you so since the
Constitutional tribunal hearing of uh of
October 2020 what we've noticed and what
we've heard from Partners in Poland such
as uh Camila ferenge from the federa
among many others is that the situation
has degraded in three specific areas
Health Human Rights and democracy and
the rule of law and then plus all of
this has been exacerbated by the
humanitarian situation as a result of
the Russian aggression in Ukraine next
slide please
so first in terms of health so we've
already heard the the jarring testimony
of of the relative of a victim of of
this barbaric law but more broadly what
we're seeing is that polish women in
drills are seeking abortion care in
other countries uh another thing that we
we should be pointing out that's
happening in Poland is that we have fake
guidelines from Civil Society actors
such as Odo yuris being cited by medical
staff who refuse to perform the
life-saving medical procedures that that
we've just heard are necessary in many
cases of uh of women who have who need
abortion care so that doctors are given
proactively provided with fake
guidelines by non-state actors in order
to to help them not provide the abortion
care that's needed and as a result what
we've seen is that a number of Polish
women have died
I want to contrast this with what is
what has happened this year at
International level
at International level the World Health
Organization has adopted abortion care
guidelines which provides very clear
guidance to States about what they
should be doing in terms of abortion
care and I'll be coming back to that
throughout the rest of the presentation
next slide
so first one of the things that these uh
these who guidelines state is that this
the right to sexual and reproductive
Health requires states to ensure
Healthcare facilities goods and services
are available accessible accessible and
of good quality and what we find is that
Poland is well outside
the norm of human rights regarding
health in both abortion care and
contraception next slide please
and so this these Maps will be familiar
because uh Mr pietron has shared one of
them but here we have two two overviews
of of abortion policies on the one hand
and contraception policies on the other
hand across the European region and what
you will find is that Poland in both
cases for abortion and contraception
stands out in this unique deep red that
we had to invent just for Poland uh on
both uh restrictive abortion care but
also poor access to uh poor policies in
relation to contraception so that women
in Poland not only can they not choose
about how a pregnancy should go forward
or not but they don't even have the same
access to contraception to decide
whether or not to get pregnant and aside
from just taking a look at how Polish
women compare with other EU member
states looking at this map were forced
to conclude that women living in Putin's
Russia have greater rights to control
their bodies than women living in the EU
member state of Poland today next slide
next I want to touch upon the issue of
democracy and rule of law and this was
alluded to by the uh by by the co-chair
of this session what we have seen is the
use of what are called slap cases this
is strategic litigation against public
participation or another way perhaps
more commonly stated is that these are
nuisance lawsuits meant to intimidate
people now these slab cases
have several purposes we could see that
they're meant to intimidate the target
of the case they're meant to exhaust
them emotionally and financially they
also serve as a public lesson to others
so that for example yustina that Camilla
ferenge mentioned is being sued as a in
part to serve as a beacon to others to
not provide assistance to other women
seeking abortion care but what we see is
that some non-state doctors use these
slap cases in order to fundraise their
anti-abortion activism and now this has
been typically targeted uh against human
rights activists in Poland working on
abortion women's rights LGBT journalists
myself and as the chair mentioned uh
myself even and one of my own staff so
that we have both been subject to court
cases to lawsuits by a specific
organization called Auto yuris the one
against my staff Remy Bak although uh
has lost it we are now awaiting payment
by although U.S for the court costs but
myself I'm being sued by Ordo yuris for
the testimony that I provided in this
setting in February of last year when I
provided testimony about the situation
in Poland next slide
yeah next yeah thank you so here's just
an overview of oh go back to one slide
yeah perfect thank you so here's just an
overview of how these court cases these
slap cases look like so as I said
there's one specifically against me for
the testimony that I provided in this
setting so uh as I said the the court
case will be in February of next year
but what's happening with me is just
small compared to what's happening to
other people in Poland one of the other
uh um Witnesses at the at the hearing of
February last year was was martial
Lampard she is the head of the women's
strike in in Poland uh the the person
who the the woman who organized those
big marches when I exchanged with her
just recently she told me that she is
now facing
106 similar cases brought either by the
state or other private actors such as
Odo yuris and so we can see that this is
a systematic attempt to silence
opponents there's a Coalition based in
Brussels called the Coalition against
slaps in Europe which identified
specifically the head of the Polish
government and this organization
although U.S in a parody contest of who
of which entities which individuals and
organizations use this intimidation
tactic the most frequently and we can
see that here it's the head of the
Polish government and this polish
organization although you has who won
the parody contest of European [ __ ] next
slide
um one word also on the Russian against
you uh Russian aggression against
Ukraine and what this means in Poland
um as was mentioned by the chair there's
a challenge of Ukrainian Refugee women
accessing abortion care in Poland but we
also hear uh anecdotes that the same
thing is happening in Hungary and
Slovakia so Poland does not stand out
particularly for this although the
volume of Ukrainian refugees in Poland
does make it a very unique issue well
we've heard what we've have also heard
about is that a number of anti-abortion
organizations again although yuris but
also other organizations are busy making
sure that Ukrainian women do not have
access to abortion care when they arrive
in Poland and I think it's worthwhile
noting that this is contrary to
international human human rights and
humanitarian law regarding abortion in
humanitarian settings
next slide
and I'll end here I think my seven
minutes are up just uh some parting
thoughts I'd like to cite once more The
Who abortion care guidelines which
clearly state that states should not
criminalize having an abortion or those
who have an abortion or those who
support someone having an abortion this
is clear guidelines to member states of
the who including Poland however in
Poland we see that it uniquely violates
women's rights to health and dignity in
a number of areas abortion care but uh
but also access to contraception
basically the whole range of a woman's
ability to control her own body
but and then also we see that there's
our there's active attempts to silence
opponents both inside Poland and outside
Poland through targeted campaigns of
judicial harassment done by the polit
state itself but by non-state actors
such as although yuris and others uh who
are aligned with with the government's
ultra-conservative agenda thank you very
much for your attention
thank you very much Mr Data for these
remarks and for the answers that you
have given us today I'd like to give the
floor now to Ms Caroline Hickson who is
the regional director of the
international Planned Parenthood
Federation European Network Ms Hixson
thank you again for having accepted our
invitation to speak today
you also have seven minutes to speak
thank you very much
um I received this invitation to speak
uh just around the same day as the 10th
anniversary of the death of Savita
halpernava in Ireland which is my native
country and it makes me so angry that
I'm listening to another testimony 10
years later makes me so angry and I'm so
sorry for your family
but it did make me think about
contrasting uh the steps that the Irish
government took with the steps that the
Polish government have taken the Irish
government was certainly no saint when
it came to abortion they paid their
heads in the sand for a long time but
after savita's death it became clear
what Irish citizens wanted and
eventually the call of the people of
Ireland was heeded and we had a
referendum and we changed the law
contrast that to the Polish government
when we know even back in 2016 when they
first launched their attack on women's
reproductive Freedom nearly
three-quarters of Polish citizens uh the
poll showed did not want further
restrictions to abortion and poll after
poll in Poland has shown that polish
citizens are not in line with their
government and their government is
deliberately ignoring and riding over
the Polish people's wishes
um they have continued cynically to push
the ban and as we've heard when they
couldn't get it through the
Parliamentary process uh they turned to
the Constitutional tribunal whose
Independence and legitimacy is
profoundly eroded and politically
compromised
um and the only people standing up to
them are the brave women and men who
come out onto the streets and who
protest in hundreds of thousands and the
brave organizations like federa like the
Polish women's strike who stand up who
speak truth to power
but they are suffering for it and Neil
already mentioned in his speech
um how activists are being attacked
through the use of strategic litigation
and slaps but they are also being
directly threatened and attacked
physically during protests footage
documented by activists and journalists
on social media showed police using tear
gas pepper spray and physically
assaulting protesters protesters
describe being hit in the face hit with
a truncheon and kicked in the groin by
police at the protests after being
pinned to the ground and this comes from
a damning 2021 report from Poland's
independent torture prevention body but
we uh ippf working with Human Rights
Watch and other civil society
organizations have also documented uh
what is happening to Civil Society
organizations at least six star from at
least six organization received bomb
threats and they live in constant fear
of their personal safety Martha lempart
head of the women's strike addressed in
ippf meeting uh in June and she said I'm
very frightened I keep going but I'm
very frightened because I know
eventually they're going to get to me
um she has as Neil says more than 100
cases against her
um but the most recent of which is
prosecutors in Warsaw filed an
indictment against her and two other
leaders of the movement for organizing
protests peaceful protests during the
covid-19 pandemic these carry the
possibility of an eight-year prison term
so we are talking about in the EU
peaceful protesters could go to prison
for eight years is that acceptable in
the European Union in 2022 I do not
think so
a specific detail worth mentioning in
the case of martyr is that one case is
also filed against her by Odo Urus uh
Neil mentioned in this specific case the
judge appointed to hear the case was
actually suddenly replaced by another
judge appointed by the president in
2021. in the judge's previous role in
the ministry of Justice she was actually
at the head of the very Department in
charge of rolling out the controversial
reforms to the Polish Judiciary which
we've discussed and which were condemned
by the court of the Justice of the
European Union the right to a fair trial
is no longer guaranteed in Poland and
Marta is facing just such a trial I
think she has every right to be fearful
but in her words because she always
thinks of others before she thinks of
herself she says I'm just one of many we
are talking about 6 000 people being
harassed for protesting who will be
taken down one by one if the erosion of
judicial Independence is not stopped
immediately
across ippf globally we see how women's
bodies are Battlegrounds on which the
struggle between authoritarianism and
democracy is being fought
in Poland the attack launched on women
in 2016 was the warning signal for the
attack on the rule of law and the right
to protest that has followed and we see
the same patterns everywhere including
in the United States
ippf International Planned Parenthood
Federation is an organization that is
supposed to be working on health care
that's what we work on sexual and
reproductive health care but we find
ourselves having to provide
organizational security expertise and
fund personal safety measures including
in EU countries this is not our job why
are we having to do this in the EU
it's crucial that the European
Parliament continues to put pressure on
the Polish government to comply with the
rule of law and fundamental rights and
allow full freedom of expression without
fear of reprisal
polish government should take genuine
steps to reform its politically
compromised Judiciary which was
instrumental in rolling back abortion
rights and has a direct effect on
people's lives and loss of life as we've
heard
Parliament must hold accountable the
European commission and EU member states
to use all the tools you have at your
disposal in this regard and a particular
note the response to the Ukraine crisis
cannot be used as a get out of jail free
card for its abuses of the rule of law
while
simultaneously attacking the very civil
society organizations and human rights
Defenders like federa sitting beside me
who are actually providing the support
to Ukrainian women and children it's
Civil Society who are responding to this
crisis
so it's critical that the European
commission stands firm on its position
that the Polish government must
relinquish executive power over judges
in order to receive the tens of billions
of Euros in Grants and loans
the EU should also insist that Poland
and all member states uphold the right
to comprehensive sexual and reproductive
Health Care as part of their fundamental
rights obligations
because without an independent Judiciary
to Ward against potential police abuses
the right to peacefully protest for the
right to Safe abortion access and for
many other things that we hold dear in
the EU
uh is under dire threat
and if it is not protected more women
will suffer the consequences and more
women will die and we'll be here in
another 10 years and we can't accept
that thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much so we have heard
four interventions very strong
interventions showing us clearly that
there is a serious issue uh not only in
Poland as we see but also in some other
member states and
as Isabella said in her text messages
less text messages
women are being treated as incubators
and that should not be a case and this
freezing effect which led to the death
of the six women so far that we know
and the pregnancy register that you know
was introduced in Poland to follow the
pregnancy and to persecute those who are
terminating their pregnancy this shows
us clearly the way some member states
are going and it reminded me when I was
hearing to these stories this dystopian
serious handmen's tale where it all
we've seen in the series you never
thought that this may happen and here we
are 2022 member states of European Union
the heaven on Earth we could think and
here we are so thank you very much for
that before we go to q a session the
first one
I want to welcome the journalist young
sorry they're not here okay
they're on the way okay so I I'm not to
welcome them yet okay
I was in front of him to welcome someone
but we wait okay then we go to q a
session uh yeah we will hear for the
first round the members of the farm
committee and Libya committee to
present their position of the political
groups and then the first one we will
have Epp from Farm committee
esca my colleague from the committee as
pieta the floor is yours for one and a
half minutes thank you so much
thank you very much chair today
I want to speak on behalf of thousands
of Polish women from cities towns and
Villages from different regions
including from my reading podcast
those women are ignored by the
government women are going through hell
this is an act of violence and
disrespect
towards women this is also an act of
blatant ignorance of medical knowledge
women are falling victim to this policy
it's only a fetus which counts and women
are supposed to be heroes all of them
the government is just thinking about
the features viable or not doesn't
matter to the government if a disabled
child disabled child is born the woman
is left to her own devices in 80 percent
of cases Partners or husbands leave such
women to their own devices without help
and the government is not helping either
Polish women want to give birth but they
do not want to die for it and they do
not want to sacrifice the happiness of
their families Polish women do not want
to watch their babies die
this voice of Polish women is not being
taken into account in the
decision-making processes that concern
the health and life of women doctors
discreetly of the record behind the
scenes say it themselves that they are
ashamed that their hands are tied they
have no room for maneuver because they
are under pressure and they might be
liable we are talking about criminal
liability penal liability here but many
gynecologists are so-called
conscientious objectors this is
unacceptable
this is very telling that I can't see
pis colleagues here my female colleagues
from pis do not have the courage to face
the situation to listen to the Polish
women and to understand what they are
they are going through because of what
their government is doing the pis
colleagues are afraid
Ireland has had a difficult situation
had had a difficult situation but the
law has been changed I have hope for
Poland I hope that after the next
elections will go in the same direction
we'll have a new government a different
government and he will scrub this cruel
barbaric law
that is that makes it makes it
impossible to remove the Fatal Earth
fetuses with fatal abnormalities our
colleague from liebe former prime
minister of Poland our colleague from
polish delegation evacopatch the floor
is yours ever
thank you very much chairman
and first of all I would like to thank
you chairman thank you for this hearing
half of the Polish Society is the topic
of this hearing half of the Polish
population Polish women there is one
million and a half more women than men
in Poland so we deserve this serious
discussion on our rights
uh dear uh ladies and gentlemen when I
heard about Isabella's strategy I have
to say that as a politician as a doctor
I was overwhelmed in the whole of Europe
because of very difficult demographic
situation we want women to have more
children but what would you do if you
were a young woman who knows that even
though her a baby is bound to die she
will have to carry the pregnancy to the
very end at her own risk so the question
arises how many people will decide to
have children when I was in Polish
parliament in Polish government I was
doing my utmost to have good family
policy so that more and more children
are born and comfortable
situation sir circumstances this was one
of them of my most important priorities
when I see how ideologically biased
politicians create hellish conditions
for women I have no words to describe
this wickedness today we're discussing a
concrete issue this is a tragedy of a
family this is the tragedy that
shouldn't have happened in a civilized
world but we're also discussing in the
shade of the fate of Iranian women
following midterm elections in the U.S
where the abortion issue influenced the
results of the vote but we have to
remember that both American women
Iranian women they
faced up they they stood up they don't
want women to be treated as objects they
are fighting for their rights and Our
obligation politicians is to defend
women in the whole of EU including
Poland my country three a women cannot
be treated as a property of oppressive
State we should do our utmost so that
Isabella's death Isabella from China is
not in vain never more a woman's life
but also their husbands fathers cannot
be a part of ideological game between
politicians enough with trading in our
bodies in our families in our health
uh it is difficult for me to talk to you
because on the one hand I'm a politician
I'm a politician but I'm also a woman
I'm a mother I'm a grandmother I'm a
friend I am a Polish woman and the death
of Isabella moved me deeply when I
thought that this could happen to anyone
any of us to any women we know that this
is something that really overwhelmed me
I am overwhelmed when I see that the
peace government crossed the line and
behind this line we only have anger
contempt to helplessness wrath and very
often as we see and following this the
death of Isabella also death Isabella
should become the patron of our movement
movement to defend our health our rights
the movement moment to defend our
freedom women's freedom and this is a
unique and the right moment
you you this hearing this day this is
the day to say stop not one more and I
would like to thank you for that
chairman
and this is the moment we were waiting
to welcome the journalists the young
employees and journalists from the Dutch
national broadcaster knows they are
called nastian Welcome where you are
Show Yourself they over there welcome
and I also want to this hearing he plays
a lot of media attention we have also a
bunch of Polish journalists present in
this room and online so welcome welcome
all and thank you very much for being
with us today at this important hearing
so now we go to snd group and then we
have two colleagues of mine who will be
representing the both committees the
farm committee
is represented from the snd group by
Fred Marty which whom I told you was
sharing the mission to Poland and has
experience with this issue discussed
today Fred the floor is yours
the koala rope thank you thank you
Robert Pietro and thank you to all the
guests to all the ladies who are here to
us today especially Madam Scrabble to
whom I wish to express my condolences
because of the loss in her family
Poland is a disgrace in the European
Union and we must Clearly say so it
became even clearer to me 10 days ago
when I led a delegation of this
committee to Poland the meetings we held
showed that the situation is even worse
than expected the best thing to
show this is to see how we were received
there so there was
a specific way that we were accepted by
the members of the same and it opposed
greatly to those men to the manner of
acceptance we received and the NGO
offices also we contacted the ministry
of the family in the Polish government
and they
said no to everything they even claimed
that Poland is the best country in the
world to live in which I do not doubt
but also
I told her that that European Parliament
we often adopt resolutions and whether
she believes it or not every second
resolution concerns Poland she of course
said this was not true and I said that
even though she is not from my political
family she is free to come as my guest
to the appear European Parliament and
perhaps to explain to all of us that
things are not such as we believe they
are
and let me just
share a few of the most shocking things
that we've heard the pregnancy register
that we discussed in our committee also
claims that this is just a part of the
procedure to upgrade their I.T structure
which means that they actually had a
attitude towards us as if we were
mentally a bit ill or disabled and they
were bragging about the numbers and
statistics and of course they neglected
the
procedures the medical procedures that
the Polish women had to perform in other
countries I also had to mention the
lgbti free zones they claimed that this
was a joke on behalf of the local
governments and activists and I asked is
this possible is this possible to take
place in Poland country that remember
three zones is it possible in Poland and
in Warsaw but they negated the reality
of homophobia and discrimination that
takes place in their country I cannot
believe that in 20 000 2022 we have a
member country in the EU that literally
kills women and manipulates the facts
while doing so anybody who believes it
is out of touch with reality or does not
care about the well-being and health of
women so two years have passed since
this ban at least six women have lost
their lives and still we hear about the
national jurisdiction and rights of
national countries and who is there to
protect the girls and the ladies and the
women in that country only a few Brave
activists who are here with us today and
I want to thank them for it be sure that
socialists and Democrats are with you
will not abandon you and we will never
give up on this fight thank you
and representing Libre from snd group I
have my polish colleague from the same
delegation
the floor is yours
I would like to thank you for this
hearing
in the period of seven years our
government has crossed many red lines of
humanity of decency
and it has also crossed the lines
endangering the health of women women
need to be allowed to choose this little
and that much it needs to be accompanied
by responsible sexual education
we also need to protect life of course
but as a state we also need to help the
victims of domestic violence I'm from
sailaja just like madame scrubble
I like working
on
solid tangible things
together with my colleague I have been
working on a report on the Istanbul
convention soon we are going to present
this report I wanted to call on the
institutions to ensure financial support
for organizations that fight domestic
violence and
violence against women
I would like to have a to ask a question
to Madame scrubble did you get an
assistance as as a family from the
Polish government what would you say
uh did you receive any help any care
from the Polish government following the
strategy thank you for being here
let us make sure that Iza will have not
died in vain not one more my promise is
that this will not be an empty slogan it
will be followed by
legislative changes that need to take
place in Poland just to wrap up about
katrinsky towards katrinsky Polish women
do not become mothers not because they
are alcoholics as the address of
katrinsky recently suggested but because
they're intimidated they are scared
katinsky you should go away from
politics
we go now for the third political group
in this house renew and the first one on
my list is my colleague from Farm
committee was a member of the mission to
Poland Korean medical current floor is
yours thank you very much chair and I
want to thank Barbara for being here and
also Isabelle's family because
standing up and saying that you have
lost family members that you have had
health problems because of the lack of
Health Care for Women in Poland is
something that takes courage both
because of the attacks the hate speech
but also the taboo that having abortions
having the need for abortions still is
in Poland so I really want to thank Mrs
scribble for being here and also
Isabelle's family
your intervention made me incredibly sad
to hear of the loss of your
sister-in-law of Isabel's loss of life
and her family's loss
this is uh correctly of joint fam Libra
committee meeting hearing
because this is the results of a
politicized tribunal justice system and
public prosecution system because these
examples of medical malpractice should
be prosecuted so that doctors in Poland
are more scared of not treating women
properly and giving them the health care
that they need than being criminalized
for proofs for having given women
abortions we have had six uh women at
least that we know of that have died due
to pregnancy complications
these doctors in these hospitals should
be sued for malpractice instead we have
doctors and health professionals that
are scared of providing health care
because they would be criminally liable
for having provided abortions this has
got to stop
during our mission uh 10 days ago as
explained by Mr Matic it was a surreal
experience
but we got guarantees from members of
the peace party saying that of course
any doctor would choose to save a
woman's Life by providing an abortion
when needed otherwise it would be the
case of malpractice
I think we should support the Civil
Society in Poland
by asking the Polish government to
explain what they do in each of these
known cases for making sure that the
women had received the medical attention
that they needed
we must be aware that this is not only a
Polish issue a lot of our polish
colleagues have been speaking out about
this today
I'm deeply sad today but I have been
angry for two years uh for the situation
of women in Poland
because this is not just Poland and
Polish women this is an issue for women
all across Europe and all across the
world
even in Denmark we see youth wings of
our political parties from the
conservatives from the Epp group and
also from right-wing extremists that are
putting in question the women's rights
to abortion
in Hungary the ministry of in Syria
decided a few weeks ago that women
should now listen to the heartbeat of
the fetus in Slovakia Ultra
conservatives are again proposing a
dangerous law which has been rejected by
Parliament last year after huge process
around the country
the position of our Parliament is clear
the full and universal access to Social
and reproductive Health rights for all
without discrimination has to be
guaranteed in Poland as well as in other
EU countries thank you so much and we
will continue to support your work
thank you very much colleague and the
next one from the same group is Maria
Soraya Rodriguez Ramos Soraya the floor
is yours
espresso
thank you Chad
let me start
by thanking
everyone
who is here particularly Barbara who's
related to Isabelle
here we've been hearing about what
happened to Isabella Marta Anya yustina
and I think we're all
feeling powerless
and I also feel shame
the situation in Poland is completely
unacceptable
it's unthinkable
the EU represents freedom and justice
it's founded on the rule of law how can
the EU allow a European government on
European soil to legislate against women
with
criminal criminal laws
and this legislation has taken their
lives away
what we have to ask ourselves is what
else can we do are we doing enough
the immediate answer to that is no we're
not doing enough
we're allow we're allowing this
government to act with impunity
it continues to legislate
using the most odious practices of
dictatorships pregnancy lists
instilling fear in doctors
threatening them with severe
penalties and many of these
doctors can't even look at themselves in
the face
uh when
they allow a woman to die
to put her life at risk
Women's Rights sexual and Reproductive
Rights the right to Safe termination all
of these are fundamental rights
there should be no
space in Poland Hungary or in any other
country for a government to legislate
against
these fundamental rights
my political group and the whole
European Parliament wants the European
Charter of human rights to include
access to termination as a fundamental
value
the commission should look at the rrf
funds
and the commissioner has been looking at
these RF funds but last
month Poland received
over 350 million euros
so this government feels safe but
there's uncertainty for women
and Women's Health and women's lives in
Poland are at risk the worst is that the
judicial system in Poland
is also instrumentalized
against half of the population
so that means that there's even greater
impunity that the Polish government
enjoys
we therefore need to Spur ourselves into
action we have to ask the commission for
much more to be done
because we can do this
and on behalf of these six victims that
we've heard about but I'm sure there are
many more
their silence
there's Terror there's denunciation all
of that means the cases are being hushed
up so on behalf of these victims their
families
let's not forget the pain of their
broken lives on behalf of them this
Parliament and the commission needs to
do more for Poland and for the whole
project gracias uh
and then we go to the greens and from
the greens I have on the one speaker on
the list it's Sylvia's Burek from the
farm committee Meister of our community
Silvia de Flores
foreign thank you very much
let me start by saying that for more
than 20 years I was working on the
rights of women and we should remember
that it wasn't in 2020 that the access
to abortion was restricted severely many
people forget this but we should look at
the entire story to draw the right
conclusions it all started in 1992.
doctors
restricted access to abortion in the new
code of ethics then a year later an
anti-abortion law was passed in the
parliament only three dramatic
exceptions were allowed we are talking
about 1993 here but even in those
exceptional cases it was in practice
extremely difficult to obtain access to
abortion that has
prepared the foundations for what
happened recently
the Constitutional Court ruled against
women but it wasn't for the first time
in 1997 the Polish constitutional courts
said that it was unconstitutional to
remove pregnancies for social reasons
then there was another judgment
concerning conscientious objectors
the fact that doctors can invoke
conscientious objection and refused to
terminate pregnancy so one thing is the
law one thing is the discourse
we are no longer the politicians no
longer talk about fetuses they talk
about children saying that abortion is
always bad
and even liberal politicians say that
abortion is always bad and best case can
be the Lesser evil I can quote the
abortion dream team they say abortion is
okay abortion is fine
a woman who thinks about terminating her
pregnancy must be reassured like this
the government is failing so the ngos
have taken over such as federa the
network of women abortion Dream Team
so the state has failed on its
obligations I'm saying obligation
because access to reproductive health
and abortion is something that the state
has an obligation to provide
iska has been mentioned several times
here there is a case against her she has
been accused of facilitating abortion
and it's possible that she will go to
prison for this
before the recent changes the law was
very restrictive now the few exceptions
that have been left had been left are
being taken away
what is Brussels saying Brussels is
saying well it's not within our limit
it's easy for commissioner for the
commissioner Madame Dali to say this
it's probably easier than looking for a
solution what I'm saying is that every
woman should be allowed to decide what
happens to her body
if that requires a change to the
treaties let us talk about the Treaty
changes why not
now I would like to ask a question to
the speakers Camila ference has already
mentioned these issues and in the same
vein I had the following questions what
are your expectations from the EU
institutions
would you uh like to see the treaty is
being changed uncle and now we go to ECR
and I have Margarita de la Pisa carry on
and I know Margarita that you signed for
the second run so maybe I give you the
floor the more more time now so you can
join your speech over otherwise you can
take the floor again later up to you I
will follow your time okay we will see
how long it takes and see if it's one
round or two
thank you colleagues again this
institution is using the Femme committee
to give an anti-democratic View and a
biased view of what the social reality
is with debates that follow a single
line without giving a contrasting or
differing view in this case this is
oriented towards uh this would be
oriented towards a defending life now
as previously stated
we went on a mission to Poland and I was
there as well under a health
circumstances abortion is possible and
the patient can present any negligence
to make sure that this has been
addressed now we understand in the
terrible case of Isabella there is still
an ongoing procedure
therefore it would be a manipulation to
bring this here as a case that is
clear-cut against Poland now looking at
the case of Poland and abortion I would
return towards the regulation in case in
the case of my country where there's
actually a support for abortion against
pregnant women in fact when you're
pregnant and you go to the doctor in
Spain they ask you if you would like to
keep your baby it is treated as an
object on which you can have a decision
with a neglect of The Human Condition
and at times there is even a second or
third a proposal to turn to abortion now
this is absolutely unintolerable
if a child is born with a disability
what happens
there is a hostile environment that
rejects the child as if the child should
never have been born this is not
something that I'm imagining and it's
something that I've experienced myself
now
it is and sometimes individuals want to
continue with their pregnancy and they
don't even have the right to be assisted
in their situation
and it is considered that the doctors
have a scientific responsibility to is
this woman to be able to pursue in the
pregnancy how can women trust a doctor
if they carry out abortion procedures
now people
that think like me are accused of
being against human rights this has
happened today and when actually what
we're trying to do is defend health and
life in uh 48 when we talk about the uh
Charter for a few fundamental rights did
did we believe at the time that abortion
was a human right clearly not now if we
look at the greatness of Life what we're
doing is just distilling it down to a
materialistic end if you want to keep
the baby fine if you don't throw it away
and therefore we are
shedding scorn on life
when it comes to the physical and
psychological health of the woman we're
not taking care of that or the fact that
a family and love that is at the heart
of that
the paternal role as well is is not a
paid tribute to and in fact the woman
should have the support of the father
women are left all alone and Powerless
so what does this mean it means that yes
we are afraid it is a dark sea and a
tormented one and it's the situation
that we can see in my country and I'm
afraid of it and feel uh very fearful
because it what we should have is to
make sure that we protect our life the
most important thing that we have Poland
is following a democratically elected
line in terms of what their values are
and it is fully in line with their
constitution as well thank you Muchos
Gracias
I just want to mention that Margarita
was also a member of the mission to
Poland I forgot to mention that thank
you very much and then last one of the
speakers on my list from this first
round is Sandra Pereira representing the
the left in our house Sandra the floor
is yours
thank you chair I'd like to thank the
panelists
thank you for sharing your experiences
and that information
we hear the retrograde views of the
conservatives
and their views on women all of that has
a direct impact on them
it affects their access to termination
and to other sexual and Reproductive
Rights
the obstacles to these rights are
backsliding civilizational backsliding
that we cannot accept
there was a question I have perhaps it
was answered perhaps not I want to hear
about the number of secret terminations
in Poland do you have those numbers
we know that poorer or more vulnerable
women are more likely to get an illegal
abortion
on the other hand a more wealthy woman
might travel abroad outside of Poland to
get a termination
we know that banning
abortion doesn't actually reduce
abortions it makes it secret
unprotected illegal and that affects
Women's Health as you've spoken about in
your testimonies with countless examples
in my native Portugal
we
ended
uh we we
legalized abortion in 2007 since 2007
there have actually been fewer abortions
let me express my solidarity with all
Polish women the panelists and we will
continue to fight for the rights of all
women thank you very much
indicated to speak in favor of her group
from Libya so Malin would you like to
take the floor
no one
thank you very much and
I must say that as some of my colleagues
have said here also it makes us very
saddened and also angry of course and
all my condolences to Isabella and her
family uh uh to your to her family and
thank you for being here with us today
it is very important
uh this law is barbaric it has been said
before it is also an emergency Bill to
all women
in Poland and across
across Europe it means that women are
left to die
it means that we are not safe in a
hospital where you're supposed to be
safe it means that you're not safe when
you seek Health Care
I mean it's the reverse World in terms
of how it in in comparison to what it's
supposed to be
and now when we hear about this
pregnancy register in addition to that
it feels like we are in the handmaid's
tale
and our job here as responsible and
having political mandate is to restore
human rights to restore women's rights
dignity and health
our
job is to ensure women's rights to
decide freely over our bodies and to
have the right to access safe and legal
abortion care
and our job resources was mentioned by
ippf and EPF and and by other speakers
is to restore the respect for democracy
and rule of law we cannot let Marta
Lampard or Justina being persecuted in
in in court systems in Poland this is
not democracy it's not a functioning
state of rule of law we cannot let
authoritarian leaders make women and the
Liberty people a Battleground our bodies
Our very bodies and lives into a
Battleground
so I think here today we have to ask
ourselves and I think the proposal is
from you speakers have been very clear
to us you want to see
that we make reproductive coercion a
kind of violence against women we have a
directive on the table on gender-based
finance just let's put it in there and
I'm looking at my colleagues here in the
European Parliament do make those
amendments make sure that it makes it
into this directive
and the other thing is you know we have
to promise each other that we don't
release funds to Poland until they can
live up to the respect for rule of law
and democracy and fundamental rights
this law was made on faulty system of
judiciary
and also who will push the European
commission to make sure that when we
look at Health we also look look at
sexual reproductive Health along the
lines that the the who have now
published the guidelines on abortion
care we need to adopt the legislation on
slaps these to stop these lawsuits
against uh public interest activists
I think it's time for accountability and
it's time for solidarity from all our Us
in the political house here and I wear
this scarf it's a green scarf that was
worn in Argentina for former women
fighting for abortion rights for many
many years and they did succeed and they
left no one behind and I would like to
say to you a Polish activist and and uh
women that are fighting for abortion
rights that we will stand by you with
you we will be determined we will be in
solidarity and we will be there to leave
nobody behind thank you
thank you very much colleague for your
last intervention in the first round of
the political groups and now we go into
replies to questions and I will give
three minutes to each speaker when we
start of course if you're willing to
speak if not you are not forced to do so
Barbara's Scrabble the sister in law of
Isabella Scrabble as the first one to is
the first one to speak Barbara
you can reply if you want Barbara the
floor is yours
asked me if my family received some help
from government
from the ministry we received an offer
of psychological assistance that was all
nothing else
that's my response thank you Camila
ference lawyer of the of federa Camila
what we expect of course the amendment
of treaties access to abortion should be
considered a human right but before it
happens there is a long process ahead of
us we need Solutions now Financial
Solutions abortion should be free of
charge for Polish women in the hollow of
the EU we cannot have a situation where
these costs must be borne by individual
women and some individual governments do
that they finance abortions for example
Danish government they finance abortions
for Polish women I think that Health
standards should be the same everywhere
and we should also have better financial
support for organizations for
foundations and we should also consider
abortion and extremely abortion in the
whole legislative process of the EU
because there is no health without
access to Safe abortion and when it
comes to this dissenting voice that we
heard I would like to say clearly our
position of feminist organizations who
fight for access to abortion we fight
for abortion or abortion which should be
the right this is clear we want both we
want support when we want to terminate
pregnancy pregnancy but we also also
want support when we decide to carry
pregnancy and a child a disabled child
is born but our government does not give
us any of this they do not ask us what
we need when we give birth to a child
and when we scream when we have protests
when carers of disabled children go to
the Polish Parliament to protest then
the Polish government turns a blind eye
and provides no support so we have two
worlds my world is the world which gives
choice and would gives support whatever
ever a decision of a pregnant woman
however in Poland those who have
children when we also fight for in vitro
right in rights to individual or if
people do not want to become parents
then in any case
the voice of interested parties of
stakeholders is ignored is undermined by
the single political option the single
political party this is not what the law
should be all about it is not about
teaching from the rooftops this is about
enabling people and helping people with
their choices
you also talked about abstract values
the Father Figure love but where was
love when Isabella was dying suffering
in a genital in in a hospital in Poland
she left behind daughter and a loving
husband love is when you listen to women
when you listen to their needs when you
help with their needs and love is not
when you publicly talk about love for
life support for families when you
deprive people of this life at the same
time and as long as the woman is not
considered to be more important than a
fetus and this is our position as long
as we do not look at everything from the
point of view of a woman then we won't
have a safer and just a Justice Society
we cannot really replace the interests
of women with the interests of a fetus
when it comes to underground abortions
the number of such abortions illegal
abortions we estimate that this is
around 150
000 to 200
000 abortions really and women have
these abortions regardless the legal
situation but costs are high
psychological emotional costs are high
women
women feel
left alone
and 70 000 Polish women since the
decision of the criminal of the Court
left Poland to have abortion the
European Parliament to foreign for
sexual
that's
um thank you for giving me the floor uh
just very briefly to uh to share some
final thoughts one of them would be on
authoritarian legalism simply because a
a government
legalizes through uh formal procedures
stripping certain people of rights does
not mean it is democratic and I think we
need to take a look at what happened in
Poland and also compare this with what
happened in the United States where
women were stripped of abortion rights
through a process of authoritarian
legalism where a democratic process
for example the 2016 Bill to prohibit
abortion in almost many in most cases in
Poland was not successful through a
formal Democratic process therefore the
Constitutional Court was weakened and
softened in order to produce the same
thing
in the United States it is the
Republican party which stacked the
courts with biased judges which
overruled Roe v Wade so we see the
strategy of
ultra-conservatives at T or
anti-democratic illiberal movements
working to weaken Democratic
institutions in order to achieve the
desired result of undermining human
rights in certain areas so I think first
of all we need to have really a rule of
law democracy perspective on this and be
absolutely
unwavering in making sure that Poland
and other member states adhere to the
basic criteria of EU membership then
finally on the question that was raised
about whether to include abortion into
the treaties or the EU Charter
fundamental rights I would say we need
to do a bit more than just abortion but
all sexual and reproductive health and
rights because as I pointed out it is
not just the right to abortion that is
compromised for Polish women but equally
their access to contraception so they
have no ability to choose the outcome of
a pregnancy whether it's desired or not
but they even have a compromised ability
to choose if and when to get pregnant
they are deprived of many of their
rights to control their own fertility
and that is a new Battleground for many
of the illiberal and anti-democratic
forces that we see in Poland but also in
other member states of the European
Union and Beyond so thank you and thank
you for your time discipline and the
last one is currently Hickson from uh
who is the original director of the
international Planet Parenthood
Federation and the European network of
it the floor is yours for three minutes
thank you um I think the main question
relevant to me was what uh Europe can do
that EU can do
um and I think as Neil has said the most
important thing is to accept no
derogation from the rule of law and the
key values of the European Union
um because it's not just about Europe
uh ippf Works in 130 countries in the
world and we see a battle a global
battle going on on the one hand between
the values that the EU espouses of
equality democracy Justice the rule of
your law multilateralism universalism
and those who would prefer
authoritarianism power control
and women's bodies are at the heart of
the battle this is how they're used so
when you see an attack on abortion or
you see an attack on emergency
contraception or you see an attack on
lgbtqi rights you can know that coming
shortly afterwards or at the same time
is an attack on the basic rule of law
so we need to be able to go to
International negotiations we need to be
able to support other countries as we
always have in Europe by Leading by
Leading an agenda that cares for people
that protects people that is dependent
on the institutions that we have fought
for in Europe it's only a few days since
the 11th of November we fought and died
for what we've built in Europe and we
need to defend it with every fiber of
our being in our own continent because
if we can't do that we cannot stand in
judgment on other countries and we
cannot support the forces in those
countries who are fighting for the same
values that we've fought for for
Generations democracies don't die
anymore because men in tanks drive over
people they die because they take the
very institutions that are meant to
defend them and they turn them around
and they corrupt them and they make them
work against the values that they're
supposed to stand for so we are civil
society we don't have so many much power
you are in positions of privilege where
you can do something so our request to
you is that you stand for these values
you you do everything you can the whole
Poland accountable to hold hungry
accountable to hold all the EU countries
who would uh go away from those values
um because we it's the only way to make
sure that we have the Europe that we
want our children and our grandchildren
to inherit and a Europe in which we
won't have panelists coming to talk
about women who die when they should be
in the care of doctors in the very place
to protect them thank you
thank you I'd like to begin by thanking
the members of parliament my colleagues
for their input their comments and their
speeches on this crucial debate and I'd
also like to thank the guests for their
answers to all of the questions that
were raised now I'd like to give the
floor to other members of the parliament
who have requested it
they will all have one and a half
minutes I know that our colleague from
the Epp perner Vice has requested the
floor therefore I should like to give it
to her now
foreign
thank you very much and I were going to
speak my native language today Danish
and express
my deep respect my very deep respect
empathy
and also Express
of course
my womanly uh solidarity with you
and thank you
for coming here today
so the debate the attention help create
creativity
all of this makes a difference
and that is something that can be not
always carried out in one afternoon in
the European Parliament
and those of us have had many years
experience that we can't just solve
things with a hearing
even in a meeting room which is very far
away from those who experience what we
are talking about today a way that
confirms their opinion that we have to
have resistance resistance
uh against
understanding this many countries ever
since uh I was born in fact and I'm not
that young we've found
a balance in this dilemma and the
ethical challenges which are linked to
the topic of abortion so I'd like to ask
you we're almost at the end of the
hearing
the next time we take an initiative
who else should be in the panel
what else could we do in order to have
those people who aren't here today
present those people who aren't going to
read about this hearing how are we going
to involve them
because we can't be in a situation uh
that 10 years from now we're going to
find out that in some countries we
haven't seen the desired changes and I
also hope
in fact that we can be proud of the way
we changed opinions
which exists in some environments very
very
sensitive topics so we'd like to
demonstrate to the rest of the world the
way we address these issues
demonstrate that democracy
is actually the Least Complicated way to
develop a society and to encourage
cooperation among
countries
so who would you really like to hear at
a hearing who would you like to involve
in addition to what we've already done
thank you
thank you
thank you Miss Vice
now on behalf of the snd group
I'd like to give the floor to Evelyn
Regner
for the Femme committee uh
thank you thank you very much Barbara
for be here for being here thank you for
your courage
thank you Ms verens Mr dutter Miss
Higgins
I thank you for the excellent determined
work you're doing
we've heard from so many
and you've seen that there's an
overwhelming majority who feels sad
angry
and there's so much
latent energy in the room so much
determination
this de facto there's so much
determination to deal with this de facto
abortion ban we won't accept it we are
determined to ensure that this ban ends
the right determination is a human right
it is a state and government failure in
Poland
this has been a failure to Isabel and to
others
the fact that these women have been
allowed to die it is our duty as the
European Parliament and as European
institutions to fight
to fight to ensure that
the polish government can't break the UN
convention on the ban of torture but
that is actually what they're doing
they're torturing women by forcing them
to
continue with these pregnancies
this isn't an issue that is in any way
related to subsidiarity this uh if
dealing with this de facto ban wouldn't
be
violating subsidiarity no on the
contrary it is up to us to do everything
that we can to protect women
we've heard firsthand about what's
happened
but there's so much latent energy in
this room the interpreters feel it too
everyone
everyone has been affected by this
men too they are brothers they are
husbands they are fathers they are
affected
any woman could be affected by this so
it's our duty
and Our obligation to do more
and what you've said is further
strengthened us in our fight
there won't just be an another hearing
there will be another set of instruments
and I want to thank you for your
concrete proposals particularly on the
issue of slaps and how we deal with them
there's also the issue of funding
because that's also quite gruesome and
then there's
EU policy related to health
equality
and so on under those policy areas it's
so important to protect women and to
include termination rights under those
areas thank you
thank you Evelyn
now on behalf of the s d group
Ms Moretti has asked for the floor thank
you very much chair I too would like to
thank Barbara
and all of the women that are here and
that fight in Poland to make sure that
this right is recognized I'd like to
turn to Margarita de la Pisa this
committee is so Democratic that she can
take the floor we all have the right to
take the floor and to give our views
but I did want to say Ms de la Pisa I
have two children no one ever pressured
me to have an abortion but I do know
many women who wanted to continue with
their pregnancy but weren't able to
felt a lot of pressure by pro-life
groups in Italy or they were did not
receive the day after pill or they had a
conscious a conscientious objectors who
stated that they would not assist in
that termination to the to pregnancy and
yet in Italy the right to abortion is
recognized as a law so remember and just
think for a second about those countries
where it is not recognized as a right so
just so we can clarify a few things here
I do believe now that there should not
be a single man a single government a
single state a single institution that
would have a right
to tell a woman who has been raped
victim of rape that she has to keep that
baby
because our colleague
Miss de la Pisa needs to explain to me
if a man
has raped a woman does he love her is
that love
I think we have to have clarification of
this point as well
now as we've all understood
recognizing abortion as a human right
that would be very challenging because
we would have to amend the treaties and
to amend treaties it takes decades I
think therefore we should work from
another angle to make sure that abortion
is recognized as a right to health
linked to health and sins health is
essential right of a human being and for
this reason and because we should be
able to practice and enjoy the right to
health that would mean that Europe can
and must act this to me would be the
best way to make abortion a and
a right for all
inalienable
and I would conclude by saying that
Europe
cannot accept a state of things in which
there are countries that are
accomplished to murder because if a
woman is faced with the choice of making
abortion or otherwise putting her own
life at risk or in the case of rape like
those women who have died that means
that a con government is an accomplice
to death this needs to be stated and
this needs to be stated loudly and
clearly because women absolutely need to
be able to have the right to
self-determination and be free
to do with their bodies as they choose
Thank you
[Applause]
thank you Alessandra
I'd like to give the floor now to Karen
melchior for the renew group
thank you that I can have the floor once
again I will also be speaking Danish
it's been a very inspiring to listen to
you today
and I will continue to have contact with
you and see how we can support you
against the attacks which are coming
from the government and religious groups
in Poland
now we've been talking today about
balance and balance in the ethical
choices being made
here we have an example that the balance
has been shifted by politicians who are
interfering in health care we have to
ensure that doctors have the possibility
of making the best possible medical
decision in order to help their patients
as a society we have to listen to what
the women want listen to what women need
and regardless of what the woman chooses
and we have to have as a society and as
politicians have to not be interfering
with health care and let give the best
possible Health Care to women that is
the balance balance is having
politicians stop interfering with Health
Care thank you
thank you very much
I'd like to give the floor now to
Mrs
thank you thank you for allowing me to
take the floor again very briefly I
would like to thank all the colleagues
present here
there are some colleagues on whom you
can always rely
today and during the plenary session
they expressed their solidarity with
Polish women their empathy
that matters that matters a lot to
Polish women I would also like to give
my condolences to the family of Barbara
and to the family of all the victims of
this barbaric law
I do hope
that the law will be changed swiftly and
I hope that such tragedies will not
happen again because no one no woman no
family no children should suffer like
this thank you
I'd like to give the floor now to Ms de
la Pisa carrion for the ECR group the
floor is yours
thank you let me answer
people aren't
we're not uh
well I I myself have been pressured to
abort
disabled children are not welcome
and there
their mothers are proposed in abortion
and we're hearing that you can't end
your pregnancy but why what would happen
to these women if they don't end their
pregnancy
what Solutions are offered to them today
the only solution put forward is
termination and that's not fair
in order to have women's
self-determination
there is pre-determination a
predetermined route the predetermined
route is abortion which is sentiment to
coercion coercion
in the name of Freedom uh Freedom has
ended
and in the case of rape
Poland does allow
termination
so there are two Clauses which state
that a termination can take place if
there has been a rape or if the woman's
life is at risk so do know that
otherwise uh abortion is being promoted
like this now I'd like to give the floor
to Maria Saraya Rodriguez for the renew
group
thank you chair I will be brief
ly
apologies briefly
this is a hearing on the subject of
abortion
and
um
has underscored Spain Spain is my
country I would like to state that in my
country in Spain women are not
put um made to accept an abortion what
is respected in Spain is a woman's right
to decide right to decide to be a mother
with a specific time frame and with full
respect with for women so considering
that we are here in a committee in a
democratic Parliament
and everyone has a right to their
opinion freely I do want to state that
there is no law in Spain like has been
characterized by our colleague
and a woman in Poland
should have a right to live in a country
in which the right to women the right to
decide to become a mother and the should
have the assistance when they decide to
become a mother because it is a right of
course for a mother to become the mother
of a child with disabilities much like
in Poland
thank you
I don't believe there are any further
requests for the floor at this time
therefore I would like to give the floor
to our guests if they would like to add
anything they have three minutes each
other
Barbara would you like to say something
I would like to say
and tell you that polish women are also
European women therefore I would like to
ask for your support EU to support
Polish women thank you
ah come in my feelings
Camila if you'd like to take the floor
I think that a lot has been said today
and we only have to recall one thing uh
the fact that something is in the law in
a document does not mean that it works
in practice and this is what is
happening in Poland the right to
abortion when uh life is threatened is a
fiction which is borne out by a lot of
cases little cases but these are also
cases we deal with in my organization in
federa
were had they not been known to us maybe
they would have ended differently so
there are a lot of cases like this and
this is a new normal in Poland women are
not safe to women are not helped because
even though we have a law we have
legislation the whole atmosphere around
abortion this ostracism for for the past
30 years abortion has been treated as
something bad to a moral evil something
that should not be taking place
therefore we forget so often that women
health and life but also well-being so
the free choice this is all menaced
right now so I think it is not
sufficient to say that we under in the
Polish law the Polish law guarantees
abortion when life is threatened or when
women were raped because Ukrainian
refugees cannot terminate pregnancy even
though they were raped in Ukraine
because the practice and the
implementation of of the law
makes them become victims for the second
time they must prove themselves that
they had been victims of sexual violence
they do not how to do not know how to
find their way in the Polish legal
system which means that they cannot
terminate this pregnancy which is
followed by a great suffering and Trauma
so abortion in Poland despite all the
Declarations is a fiction there that's
why we are here today and we would like
to call upon the EU to consider this
matter seriously and take decisive steps
to change this situation thank you
now I'd like to give the floor to Neil
data if he is still connected remotely
for three minutes
um thank you very much
um I'll be very short I'd like to say
that first of all I consider myself to
be very pro-life
uh to the point where I deeply regret
having had having heard the testimony of
the loss the unnecessary loss of six
lives of Polish women
I also am very fearful about the loss of
lives a future about the future
potential loss of life of Polish women
and that's why I think if we are
pro-life we need to recognize that
abortion is part of life and we need to
make sure that it legally safely
available so that women can have the
life and Destiny that they would like
with their families and their loved ones
and I think for that reason we need to
really consider how it is that we can
guarantee
and the right to abortion the right to
life of women in the European Union in
the future treaties thank you very much
thank you
now Ms Carolyn Hixson for the last
speech the floor is yours for three
minutes
I think all I want to do is to say thank
you because I've heard from the floor
from the parliamentarian some of the
strongest advocacy stronger the
strongest support
um and that keeps us going it keeps the
activists going we need a movement we
need a European Movement we need a
global movement and we're all part of
that wherever whether we're a politician
whether we're a civil society employee
whether we're in a Grassroots activist
it's only by being together on the same
team and standing up together
um that we will ensure that women have
reproductive Freedom that women are safe
and that women no longer die so I just
want to say thank you to all of you and
thank you to the organizers for inviting
us foreign
thank you really thank you so much from
the bottom of my heart
thank you for your presentations this
afternoon
you really gave us a better
understanding of this really difficult
situation one that involves all of us
thank you for the full participation and
the questions that you have raised on
this extremely important issue as a
European Parliament
we called for article 7 to be triggered
but we should do much more and that is
something that we are committed to
collectively such that we can put an end
to this shameful
this inhuman inhumane practice and a
violation of women's rights in an
inalienable right that many of our
colleagues have
referred to so we must put an end to all
of this
and
let's hope that we don't have to have
another meeting of this sort let us
bring this to an end we shouldn't have
to speak about it ever again I know it
is hard we have to do it for women
because these women deserve to have this
specific attention paid to them thank
you to everyone
[Applause]
thank you Vice chair from Libya
committee or participation at this joint
hearing of Lee Ben Fam thank you very
much for all the contribution that I I'm
sure we all agree that uh
that any girl any woman not only in
Poland not only in Europe but all around
the world will never walk alone we will
be in solidarity and we are in
solidarity and this should be the
message from today thank you very much
and with this I close the joint hearing
of Lee band farm and I make two minutes
break for resemble of the farm Committee
in this room thank you very much have a
good afternoon